♫
♫ ♫
>> Juan: IF YOU’RE LOOKING TO
GET UP CLOSE AND PERSONAL TO
BILL AND HILLARY CLINTON, YOU
ARE IN LUCK.
THEY ARE ANNOUNCING THEY ARE
GOING ON A NORTH AMERICAN TOUR.
THEY WILL VISIT FOUR CITIES AND
NINE MORE IN 2019.
IT’S DUBBED AN EVENING WITH
PRESIDENT BILL CLINTON AND
FORMER SECRETARY OF STATE
HILLARY RODHAM CLINTON.
DANA, ARE YOU BUYING A TICKET?
>> Dana: GOT TO GO TO BED
EARLY THAT NIGHT.
I THINK THESE WILL SELL OUT.
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO WANT TO SEE
THEM.
SHE DID WIN THE POPULAR VOTE AND
HE IS POPULAR AMONGST PEOPLE.
IF YOU LEAVE YOUR BUBBLE AND GO
OUT IN THE COUNTRY, I’M ALL FOR
IT, IT’S A GREAT WAY FOR THEM TO
BE OUT AND ABOUT TOGETHER.
GREAT THING TO DO AS A COUPLE.
PETER AND I WILL BE COMING TO A
CITY NEAR YOU WITH THE DOG.
>> Juan: I THINK BILL CLINTON
HAS NOT BEEN HAVING A GOOD TIME.
THE ANTI-KAVANAUGH ADS, THEY’VE
GOT CLINTON IN THEM.
>> Jesse: IT’S A ME TOO
BOOMERANG.
HILLARY IS BRANDED AS A LOSER.
SHE LOST BIG TIME.
DEMOCRATS ARE KIND OF ANGRY AT
HER.
SHE WAS A TERRIBLE CANDIDATE.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE CLINTONS AND
THE OBAMAS, THE YOU HAD TO GO
FORMER PRESIDENTS AND FIRST
LADIES WHO ARE EXTREMELY
POLITICALLY ACTIVE.
EXTREMELY PARTISAN.
THEY ARE IN THE TRENCHES
THROWING HAND GRENADES AND IT
SUCKS UP A LOT OF OXYGEN.
IT MAKES THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
LOOK LIKE THE PARTY OF THE PAST.
IT’S NOT A GOOD LOOK FOR THEM.
>> Juan: THERE IS A BROADWAY
PLAY COMING NEXT YEAR ABOUT THE
CLINTONS.
>> Dagen: GOODY, GOODY.
I THINK BILL AND HILLARY’S
WEDDING ANNIVERSARIES THURSDAY.
THEY WILL HAVE BEEN MARRIED 43
YEARS.
I THINK SHE SHOULD GO ON THE
ROAD AND AT ONE OF THESE EVENTS
LET HIM HAVE IT.
LOSE HER MIND AND GO AFTER HIM
FOR EVERYTHING THAT HE DID.
>> Jesse: I WOULD BUY A TICKET
FOR THAT.
>> Dagen: THEY SHOULD PAY FOR
YOU TO DO THAT.
PAY-PER-VIEW.
GO AFTER HIM.
I PUT UP WITH ALL OF THIS, ALL
OF THE PHILANDERING ALL THESE
YEARS, AND I LOST TO THAT MAN?
PLEASE.
THAT WOULD BE AWESOME.
>> Juan: THAT MAN?
WHAT’S THAT LANGUAGE?
>> Greg: I HAVEN’T CHECKED BUT
I THINK THE CLINTON TOUR IS NOT
GOING TO WISCONSIN.
[LAUGHTER]
SHE IS THINKING AS SHE IS DURING
THE TOUR, IT WILL PAY FOR THE
RENOVATION AND THE SECOND HOUSE
AND HE IS THINKING HOW AM I
GOING TO SCORE GROUPIES WITH HER
AROUND?
>> Jesse: HOW MUCH MONEY DO
THEY REALLY NEED?
>> Greg: HE IS ONLY GOING TO
THE STATES WHERE THERE IS A
HOOTERS AND A LOCAL BUT HAVE
REALLY FREQUENTED REST OUT.
>> Juan: MICHELLE OBAMA IS
ALSO GOING OUT ON HER TICKET
PRICES ARE EVEN HIGHER.
>> Dana: ONE ABOUT MOST
POPULAR PEOPLE IN AMERICA.
>> Dagen: MUCH BIGGER VENUES.